I mean but yeah people been throwing
stuff I saw someone through uh something
at Drake you heard about it oh yeah
two days yeah a giant giant titties yeah
that's the other thing it's like there's
so much positive feedback to throwing
[__] now like that shorty that threw her
bra up she got the deal with Playboy
yeah and Drake kind of encourages it
hell yeah he does yeah
yeah Drake's Drake's a heavy King bro
Drake's a heavy King bro you know what I
mean shout out to the Heavies she got a
deal with Playboy dude oh we all went to
the Drake show did we talk about that no
we didn't talk about the Drake show
thoughts I thought it was awesome yeah
production fantastic production
absolutely fantastic and the amount of
money I don't even think the fans
understand the level like the the amount
of money that he spends
to make the show like that
this is gonna sound like I'm pocket
watching I'm doing the opposite but it's
like I was talking to the people at MSG
and they were like this is an arena show
sorry this is a stadium show that has
been put into an arena in other words
the amount of production truck
specifically there's like 49 trucks or
something like that that are traveling
with all the gear
and it's done in an arena normally that
would be in an arena 15 to 20. it's a
big show yeah so that's all think about
that's just for anybody who comes and
watch the show that's reinvestment into
The Fan Experience that's money out of
his pocket yeah for the fans to enjoy
the show yeah that is an unbelievable
yeah
that is an unbelievable thing an
unbelievable dedication to a curating an
awesome Fan Experience and that's
probably why he's been one of the
reasons why he's been on top of the game
for so long because he is making sure
that every time he goes out that the
fans expect appreciate it my theory on
that is I don't he's never really had
the show that people talk about after oh
they've always been good but you know
how everybody talks about Kanye
so he's like all right this is one thing
we got to check off we gotta have illest
live show I mean yeah and again Drake is
not necessarily for me but I understand
this guy's probably gonna go down to the
greatest ever and I didn't see the show
but I I keep hearing about it he's and
he just seems like he's incredibly
thoughtful in everything he does he does
an interesting thing though which is
like he purposely
like raps kind of like off beat
at times and I'm assuming purposely
because the guy is a professional rapper
what the [__] ever he wants on a beat
and uh but
I wonder I have to ask like why that is
and what is because what it does is when
you're in the crowd you want to wrap
along with the song but it throws you
off a little bit from wrapping along
with it so he'll like create his own
other version of how the flow would go
does that make sense did you guys notice
this too I noticed it so in I'm assuming
this is all done because he believes
that that will curate the best
experience but as someone who this is my
first like big Drake show I was like oh
I kind of want to wrap along with the
song The Way I Know It And then it kind
of made that a little bit difficult
again I wish that I had seen another
Drake show so I could be like oh it's
actually cool to hear this other
stimulus because you know how the song
sounds like maybe that's what it is if
you've gone to more than one yeah I've
seen previous drink shows and does he do
it at those shows as well no so this is
the first time he did his first tour
that he's doing this and did you prefer
before or this one before interesting
being able to wrap along with the song
and then if he doesn't say a word you
just hear the crowd falling off the word
yeah one of the coolest things about
going to uh uh any kind of religious
moment you go to a church what are
things you're going to uh concert is
seeing how excited the people get
rapping along like I find myself
watching the people and these girls and
dudes were having the [__] time of
their life rapping along to the bars and
especially when he was just letting the
audience sing it yeah when he like pulls
the mic back and now it's your time to
shine your time to show how much you
appreciate the artist so yeah I thought
that that choice was interesting I'd be
curious to ask him why do you choose to
do that thing because for me it threw me
off a little bit Yeah but the whole show
is so curated I'm assuming there's a
reason there has to be no yes
like even the break there's a moment I
don't want to give too much of the show
away I don't know how that works with
with artists like maybe it's I'm curious
because with the stand up I wouldn't
want people giving my show away but
maybe with an artist
since you're already familiar with the
music you that's an okay thing to talk
about but there is a moment of the show
where he like turns it into like a club
and you play like the dance song like
kind of bangers and it's just an
interesting choice where like in the
middle of the show he's in a DJ booth
yeah and then just creating like this
different I loved it the way he did it
was so smart [__] brilliant instead
of standing on stage while it's Just
Dance beats he goes in a DJ booth and
actually like makes it about everyone
else that's there with the people
they're with sure like there's so much
psychology happening throughout the show
that I thought was really clever really
small I don't want to give it away but
like there's a the way he utilizes like
the space that he's in is this massive
Arena and he's like every person that's
in there I feel like has a moment where
they're like oh I'm close yep and great
community building the way he builds
community and then the way he's like
making the audience feel like they're
getting the most amount of show possible
at the end yeah let's not give away a
few things he does but it's that there's
some very
this is really thought about yeah and
really fun and he's not a lazy performer
there are certain rappers that like go
out there and they just try to be cool
they just chill or whatever like that
and it's just like boring as [__] yeah
singing voice was great yeah yo he was
singing singing he was singing singing
but he's going after he's moving around
the stage is even Dynamic different
parts of the stage are raising up the
whole stage is a LED so you can create
different projections on parts of the
stage so the stage itself is part of it
like
it was very and then the catalog of
music is so strong like yeah it's like
one of the advantages of just having
Decades of albums that come out that
people love you know that you can
yeah go through them it's hard to talk
about it without like revealing some of
things you want to be a surprise for the
audience but it was very it was very
cool this I saw his show and I was like
oh wow it's fantastic all the stuff he's
doing and then yesterday I see Beyonce's
show amazing
so she's doing a combination of her old
stuff and new stuff it's probably a
little bit more than new stuff so I'm
not that familiar with the newer stuff
like the dance album that she put out or
whatever but it's still it's so
stimulation everywhere background dancer
the crowd is going nuts everyone dresses
up for a concert so like every it looked
like burning man yeah just
Bedazzled and gays everywhere yeah but
um yeah that was probably one of the
best concerts I've ever really and how
does she create Intimacy in such a huge
Stadium same as Drake like she has a
stage where it's like she's kind of
walking aisles so she kind of there's
screens everywhere that you can lock in
English Sky gigantic screen and where
are they located
no right behind her oh is the is the
show on one end zone so she's not oh
this is what Taylor Swift did also yeah
bring it up she did I told you she did
the Cowboy stadium ATT Stadium yeah it's
a hundred thousand it seats but she cut
it to 70 and it did three times which is
insane but I'm assuming she just just
stayed in the end zone and performed but
keep in mind it's a hundred thousand
that seat for a football game yeah you
know now you have all the people that
are on the floor oh yeah [__] yeah so
she cut it down probably good amount to
make it as intimate as she could
oh wow bro no but fine there's a certain
stage design that's like and that wall
is so big no matter where if you're in
the nosebleed you're still enjoying the
show because you're looking at that
giant video that's not this interesting
interesting but something like this Al
yeah got it so she has two different
runways that she could walk out and
there's a camera on her locked at all
point in time and then everybody are
looking at those screens in behind to
yeah okay and the sound in that big
place sounds crisp perfect wow wow you
you know that they put like a huge team
on this the amount of money like if
Drake's spending money she's spending
double wow just put it like that wow
it's crazy bro but also does the arena
or a stadium give you more production
capabilities than an arena
like are you able to do more I wonder if
like there's a probably she was doing
[__] where she's like floating and [__]
like fireworks probably and yeah all
that wow
I don't know what that means but if it's
the biggest tour ever it's probably
pretty good I'm trying to go next week
all right we're at in L.A that's awesome
yeah yeah can't wait yeah that'd be
[__] sick I mean you just got to see
it you just gotta see it there's gonna
be aspects of the Beyonce show or Drake
show or Taylor show or any of these
things done on the highest level that
you're like oh wow those are great
things yeah we need to find a version of
that that works for us yeah like yeah
it's just like it's just like you're a
young filmmaker and you see Tarantino
put out a movie and you're like oh I
didn't even know that you could mess
with time yeah the story could still
make sense yeah yeah like and at its
best a live show is its own performance
like just because you're great at music
or great at any art form there's not a
live show transitions do a different
thing yeah listen the reality is is that
even if you don't like Taylor Swift yeah
you probably know more of her songs
she's
bangers everywhere a new artist that you
will like yeah so you can't even say you
don't like her yeah we're all swifties
like your body yeah
body has memorized her songs yeah the
point is yeah yeah we're all swifties
that that is it we are all swifties
whether you like it or not that's the
power of music whether you like that
person or not you don't gotta like her
as a person but the music you know it
and it slaps it goes bro no she got some
slappers team Kanye fine but the music
slaps with Taylor You Belong with Me
Shake It Off Shake It Off yeah
save a blank space baby
I knew you were trouble when you walked
in yeah I knew that one bro love story
you say yes
keep going I wonder how many we at least
we are never ever ever getting back
together keep going oh bad blood I don't
remember
[Applause]
so think about you going into the
concert like I'm not even gonna know
anything yeah and then you know
of course uh Teardrops On My Guitar that
was like her OG hit I didn't know that
one it's basically just like you I've
teardrops my guitar it's like the most
basic like country pop she was like 14
when she made it our song our song is
the slam the screen door speaking out
way tapping on your way
and you talk real slow that's what she
was like thank you so much yeah I know
yeah I just bro me with Brandon Yuri
that [__] goes hard
though today was a fairy tale Banger by
white horse